je pense que la montagne n'est pas un
endroit pour faire du sport
ouais je suis un peu énervé là je vous
dis ça parce que cet été on m'a obligé à
faire une
randonnée des gens on déjà fait ça ou
j'ai marché 7 he pour unune montagne
j'ai mis plus de temps pour aller en
haut de la montagne que pour partir en
vacances à la
montagne je crois que le guide était un
peu particulier en plus qu'on était en
bas il m'a dit tu vas voir Paul en haut
c'est super beau
on est arrivé en
haut il m'a dit tu as vu en bas c'est
super
beau je su dis ben je sais on y était
tout à
l'heure pourquoi on n'est pas resté
là-bas du
coup tu veux que je te mette toi dans
les yeux c'est ça je suis pas une petite
hein
je crois qu'il a même cru que j'étais un
peu stupide il a rajouté un prê c'est
très important à la montagne Paul pense
à bien
respirer il s'est dit si je lui dis pas
il va
oublier très particulier ce monsieur à
un moment aussi il s'est mis à crier
très fort et il s'est justifié en disant
que c'était pour éloigner les animaux
dangereux je lui dis certes mais là on a
encore au supermarché monsieur donc
calmez-vous on na pas croisé d'animaux
très dangereux d'ailleurs dans cette
montagne on a juste croisé une petite
marmotte qui creusait des trous et le
guide m'a dit tu ne réalises pas à quel
point c'est
extraordinaire
non si on avait croisé une marmotte qui
fait du
scooter là ça aurait été extraordinaire
monsieur ah je suis un peu énervé là on
a croisé un lac aussi d'ailleurs dans
lequel il y avait des des poissons et
pendant une seconde je me suis
dit
comment ils sont arrivés
jusqu'ici mais il a 7 he de
marche peut-être que c'est la marmotte
qui il a déposé en
[Applaudissements]
scooter